je vous le disais dans le titre le
jugement est donc tombée en début
d'après midi guillaume masse et son
époux cathy munch massé viennent d'être
condamnés dans l' affaire de
détournement de fonds au détriment de
l'association la page 37 lui écope de 18
mois de prison ferme elle 18 mois avec
sursis mais surtout cinq ans
d'inéligibilité leur maison va également
être confisquée elle les conséquences de
cette condamnation avec florent clavel
catimini je passais accusent encore le
coup quelques minutes avant la
présidente a asséné son argumentaire
elle savait tout de la situation
financière critique de son couple elle
ne pouvait pas non plus ignorer
l'origine frauduleuse de l'argent qui
atterrissait sur son compte juin
condamné l'ancienne première adjointe
socialiste au maire de tours 18 mois de
prison avec sursis cinq ans
d'inéligibilité et d'interdiction
d'exercer dans la fonction publique un
jugement conforme aux réquisitions et
prononcé sans coup férir madame
massaient dans sa défense a fait preuve
d'une mauvaise foi caractérisée a ajouté
la magistrate
oui elle a profité en conscience de
l'argent détourné par son mari une
analyse que conteste l'avocat de l'élu
qui dénonce l'absence d'instruction qui
a pas eu de juge d'instruction de saisie
ce qui ne permet pas forcément d'amener
des éléments vraiment probant et je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de subjectivité
aussi dans l'analyse du dossier
d'ailleurs vous l'avez noté madame le
président note justement
qu'à son avis
madame ne pouvait pas être naïve
elle l'a certainement été beaucoup trop
pour guillaume massés en revanche la
sphère a été vite pliée direction la
prison à partir du 29 mars et ce même
s'il fait appel il écope en tout et pour
tout deux trois ans de prison dont 18
mois ferme deux peines d'inéligibilité
d'interdiction d'exercer dans la
fonction publique il faut dire que les
faits qu'il a toujours reconnus sont
d'une exceptionnelle gravité selon la
présidente de 2018 jusqu'à son
arrestation l'an dernier l'ancien
directeur de la page d'indre et loire a
siphonné l'association pour personnes
handicapées dans des proportions folles
350000 euros au total grâce à de fausses
factures émises sur des travaux dont ils
avaient la mainmise totale
pour rembourser l'association la justice
a choisi de confisquer la maison du
couple à tours nord dont la valeur est
estimée à 433 milles euros le couple a
maintenant dix jours pour faire appel
faute de quoi cathy minsch massa devra
démissionner immédiatement de ses
mandats d'élu à la ville de tours et à
la région
et le maire de tours dans un communiqué
rappelle que cathy munch massé a bien
été démise de ses fonctions de première
adjointe elle reste en revanche toujours
élu tant que tous les recours
judiciaires n'ont pas été épuisées